hello film courage
watching this my name is Richard
really here today to tell you a little
bit about myself how I had in the
scriptwriting why I'm passionate about
it as well as share a little bit with
you about a script that I'm currently
working on so let's jump right in I've
been a writer for about a year now I've
always been a huge lover of film but
it's relatively recently that I started
writing I studied Japanese an undergrad
and then I went to business school for
my graduate degree so it wasn't
something that I studied in school it
was during grad school I decided that I
wanted to write yeah but I knew at the
time I really didn't have the time that
I want to dedicate to it so it was
actually about a year ago little bit
more than here I was working full-time
in Washington DC and I just decided that
I wanted to save up money for a few
months take some time off and dedicate
myself fully to ride so fell in love
with it pretty immediately and I've been
riding diligently ever since currently
working on is both a psychological or
and a supernatural or all rolled into
one absolutely terrifying but also very
compelling and unique story I think
people are really going to enjoy one of
the ideas that I wanted to really build
this story on is that we all have these
symbols in our everyday lives that I
think emotionally and visually represent
to us safety or puri and in a way that
they can't be touched by anything
sinister or evil and I wanted to take
those symbols and really flip them on
their end in a way that I think people
are going to find really intriguing and
different so I've been writing the
script for about three months it's
nearly complete I'm just putting the
final touches on it and yeah I'm really
excited to get it done so I can share
their I'd say the major reason that I
never quit on this script is because I
knew the elements that it's built on are
very universal stores really built
around the fear of isolation aloneness
and abandonment both in a literal and
figurative sense and I knew that
everybody can identify
that on some level so obviously the way
that that plays out in my script as some
areas that come up are not typical ones
that people would deal with regularly if
ever but I knew that you know anybody
watching a viewing my story will you
know immediately understand what that
character is going through and I think
it's really important to make that
connection I'd say definitely the
coolest story that i'd have so far as a
screenwriter is how i got started with
it so basically i recognized when i was
getting started that i just wasn't in a
position to really dedicate as much time
as i wanted to you know full-time job
social life there's no way you can do
all of that and also write 12 hours a
day so my mother actually was born and
raised and grew in Jamaica and I still
have family there so I pretty much saved
up money over the course of about three
months and then I quit my job move down
to Jamaica for two months and the goal
was get down there finished my first
script so that's what i did move to a
tropical island which was an interesting
place to be when writing horror but you
know it was a fun juxtaposition but
basically went down there the day before
I feedback to the United States I
finished my first script some that
screen writing is really taught me is
that you can't really understand a world
you're creating until you're in the
midst of creating it and what I mean by
that is many of my stories my characters
their traits their personalities
motivations their interactions with each
other all of those things started out a
certain way and very much took on a life
of their own as my scripts developed so
my big takeaway from that honestly was
that art is a very living and breathing
thing it not only means different things
to different people
but it affects us in very you know
drastically different ways so it's
really an amazing experience to kind of
bring that world to life well bro
as you're creating it typically right
during the evenings or the night time
I'm definitely a late my personal I like
working and kind of just running on a
late schedule I'm definitely the most
creative I'd say during the hours of
between the hours of nine pm and 3am so
that's when I typically do my best work
at the same time writing and other night
I think definitely helps with writing
so it's been very helpful I'd say
my biggest initial goal with the
screenwriting is to really deliver on
making sure that I trade the best
version of the stories that I want to
tell but you know bigger picture
ultimately I just want to create
compelling stories for curious people
you know from when I was young I had a
lot of really weird but interesting
stuff going on in my head story-wise I
don't see them anywhere else and for me
I just wanna share him with as many
people as possible and I think there's
no better feeling than taking something
really created in your head and putting
it down on paper and check lastly just
want to say thank you a phone courage
for this opportunity and thank you to
anyone else who's watch this I
definitely appreciate your time I hope
you can tell that I'm really passionate
about this it's important to me I put a
lot of time into it and I'm excited to
keep going with it so thanks for sharing
your time I hope you enjoyed it I really
enjoyed sharing with you and yep I'm
going to be excited when I'm able to not
to share this script I've been telling
you about but a lot of the other ones
that I've completed and I'm working on
as well so looking forward to